there was a classic Supreme Court
definition of horn which is that you may
not be able to describe it but you know
when you see it and I think sometimes
the biases are this thing in ways here's
an unconscious bias that many men have
oh I don't want to give her too much
work if she just had a baby he thinks
he's doing you a favor or he's doing
that woman a favor when in fact he's
withholding a response to help with
holding an opportunity when you notice
other people having those unconscious
biases instead of glasha ng out at them
notice what it does to you start with
how you feel and not being a victim to
unconscious bias and then you begin to
act in a way that is inconsistent with
the way they're treating you if somebody
says a joke that's obviously an
appropriate then you don't have to
correct them on it if you don't feel
comfortable doing that but you certainly
don't have to laugh at it either but the
very first step that you should take is
to actually have a conversation with the
person bring it back to how you felt
with that at that time so when this
happened when I looked around the board
room and I saw that there were no other
women or that a woman was intentionally
excluded from this meeting here's here's
the effect of that here's how I felt if
nipping it in the bud with the
individual doesn't work you can either
go to your boss or the HR department if
you want to go to HR then definitely
make sure that you have documentation
make sure that you got it an email make
sure you've got a witness if you can
know when to leave is another thing too
so you don't have to subject yourself to
an environment that you feel is toxic so
whenever you think through what what the
worst is that could happen and then you
get ready to deal with the worst
in stock and a beat lined up you're
ready to go even in the worst case
scenario and I guarantee you it'll
almost never be the worst case scenario